2021 is looking to be a pretty great  year for pc gaming  while the pc platform stands on its own  in many ways in terms of heightened  performance  the start of the next generation of  consoles means better graphics  and new game experiences for everyone pc  players included  so let's get ourselves excited for some  of the hottest upcoming games to look  forward to playing on our fancy gaming  rigs  remember to hit subscribe and ring the  bell if you haven't already  and start making a list of what you're  looking forward to playing  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  hmm  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  so  [Music]  that's what i'm talking about  [Music]  classroom  [Music]  [Music]  yo check this out